several young people from the west las
vegas community spoke directly with law
enforcement today in onnoya rights
workshop this happened at doolittle
community center 8 news now reporter
victoria saha was there she joins us
live in the newsroom tonight with a look
at how these events help build trust on
both sides victoria
hey sasha the teens and law enforcement
i spoke with say events like this helps
them understand both perspectives if
they were to be approached by police and
know the right steps to take this
program kicked off when trayon martin
was killed in florida in 2012. you may
remember martin was 17 when he was
walking home and was shot and killed by
a neighborhood watch volunteer george
zimmerman zimmerman claimed it was
self-defense although martin was
unharmed
since then there have been numerous
police encounters with people of color
that have made headlines today's
workshop was led by attorneys and law
enforcement to show the community of
color what their rights are when
approached by police and what not to do
to escalate a situation it's just making
them feel comfortable and letting the
youth know that hey we're here to
protect and serve you know
again i think the issue at hand is it's
a lot of
a lot of things they see on youtube a
lot of things they see on social media
officer hunt grew up in the northwest
las vegas area he says he saw negative
interactions with law enforcement
growing up which made him want to become
an officer to change that
a key takeaway from this event is to let
youth know if they were to encounter
police then they just need to stay calm
and comply running away is not the
option reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now